it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what up y'all it's movie fights
hashtag movie fights live Happy
Thanksgiving
that's a turkey I hope your I hope
you're eating turkey and I hope you're
not eating
owls hoot hoot what up al nation hashtag
al nation we're Micah hooligans at its
movie fights we got the honest trailer
boys in the house oh yeah it's always a
good time when these this house is
divided against itself and these pals go
to war in the movie fights squared
circle first you know him you'll love
him he's got a nice beard joestar very
much Hal Rudnick Oh Joe what's going on
up here I don't know if I told you that
last Oh
thanks brother I appreciate it you know
who doesn't like it my fiancee she's
like the least she is like the anti
mustache Club but I appreciate that this
young man he's the most finicky eater
you'll have at your Thanksgiving Day
table yeah Spencer Gilbert Thank You
Helen if this doesn't work out with the
mustache she goes stand outside Italian
restaurants beckon them inside you know
noted
I was just having a light fun
stereotyping you're doing going to have
to issue an official apology and this
man is the movie fights champion and you
know I'm from all over screen junkies
and all over internet movie trivia
Schmoe downs etc dan Merle yes and I
will take issue
anyone that set of Thanksgiving with me
knows that I am the most finicky eater
you will ever have three things Oh what
are those things at a Thanksgiving
dinner yeah turkey yep it's a sweet
potato casserole or pie and bread all
right you know what you just took the
crown and and Dan for the record belt
not on the line today know that there
are machinations underway soon to get to
get a belt match together Billy
businesses nodding yes we all got roped
into this because apparently this isn't
how people want to spend their
Thanksgiving okay thank you fellas and
deciding each of the questions and the
points and the rounds we have on and
Daniel the London Calling
[Laughter]
la terrasse how you doing my friend
doing great yeah I also enjoy your
moustache so well done you're gonna
prove it all around thanks brother and I
enjoy you being a pillar of owl nation
or it's the rear admiral of our owl
nation proud proud to call myself over
here ab mo so one and I will be chiming
in with our thoughts and decisions on
each question four hours three rounds
and your poll will also decide a vote
[Laughter]
we'll all be deciding usually our social
media ambassador now just an ambassador
of goodwill fund and her opinions
Danielle Radford what up but I will be
around the regular movie face time I'm
going to be going through your comments
and retweeting and looking at some of
the stuff that you'll see because you do
such good work every week so please
movie fights live on the hashtag I am
going to be in there and I'm going to be
active also thank you fans for inviting
me to buy yams I almost forgot you got
games citing yams dude have the Ames
handy get those yams handy and handy am
candy yep so sorry swallowing here once
again here's how it works this is a
best-of-seven first person to four
points wins so there are three regular
rounds our two top performers of these
three will move on to the speed around
that it's anybody's ballgame someone can
be down three oh and make a furious
comeback in the speed round again first
player to four takes the day jte drop
that sick-ass package
ladies and gentlemen its main event time
[Music]
thank you for Thank You Thor all right
gentlemen y'all ready for this oh yes do
it
okay let's do it Creed two hits theaters
this week so we asked what classic 80s
movies should get a new sequel focused
on the main characters son okay a lot of
a t-slot funny the movie to choose from
and we'll start with player number one
Joestar went with Michael and stars kid
from The Lost Boys the Joel Schumacher
weird vampire classic just lots of weird
Neverland Peter Pan overtones lots of
vampire boardwalk action movie look
babies are big again everybody that
everybody loves this stuff we've got the
the we've got the Amblin covered with
stranger things now we need to get like
the real weird neon every dude has like
long rocker hair and like long earrings
and denim vest with no sleeves that's by
definition of vest so yeah I think you
take Michael Starr who were a couple in
the original Lost Boys and they have a
kid who moves back to that grandpa's
house and and she finds out that when
two people that were vampires for a
minute have a kid that kid ends up
having some weird vampire stuff going on
you throw in Corey Feldman as the Logan
version of the Frog brother and there
you go man
Lost Boys too but lost boy singular all
right just one last boy boy and it's a
girl well lost boys too : lost boy
yep that's it that's the whole pitch I
like it Spencer Gilbert no to the more
streamlined title it's coming from
America look it's a lose-lose situation
because if you pick a crappy eighties
movie as Joe did people are gonna like
why you're bringing that back but if you
pick a great 80s movie it's like coming
for America people like oh really you're
gonna do better than that but I think
the Creed showed that you can take a
revered classic update it and people
will buy in if you can include you know
the people from the original little bit
of buy-in from them not a lot and I have
a whole movie pitch it basically centers
around Prince Hakeem son has been raised
in Los Angeles by adopted parents you
don't know why he's not with his dad and
he's been raised by like a like a
Madonna and like like a Brad Pitt who
like adopted this African kid and like
he's totally sheltered he's like Jaden
Smith basically and he goes to he finds
out he's a prince from Arsenio Hall on
the streets and he goes back to find his
father but it turns out that Eddie
Murphy is kind of like like Idi Amin
without the genocide like he's been
deposed so he's not he's like kind of
hiding on the run so you basically have
Jaden Smith and his like and his sibling
who's one of the biological siblings he
had like a like a Jonah Hill type on the
road throughout Africa going through
barium mines like going through the big
cities the the wilderness trying to find
his dad and it takes him all the way
around the world all the way back to
Queens where Eddie Murphy is is living
and he finds out that his real family
was with them all along all right we got
the pitch there for coming from America
Thank You Spencer
Dan Merle I'm going with a movie that's
a little lesser-known than these other
two but it is certainly an 80s classic
to me and so many other people and that
is the film the wizard the wizard if you
know it was Nintendo the movie it
introduced the power glove it introduced
Super Mario Brothers 3 I want to see
what is the next generation of the
wizard you have this kid Jimmy who was
the phenomenon of phenomenons yeah
that's right mmm that's the singular
back in the late 80s Early 90s he now
has a kid
he's 17 18 years old and but this kid
now lives in such an advanced world if
you look at the end of the wizard that
that is overwatch like that tournament
at the end of the wizard is what is
happening now in video games so you have
this kid he's got this like this his dad
is like the the king of Kong of video
games he has to live up to that
potential is live up to that title in a
world now where video gaming is is a
spectator sport and I think that it
would pay homage to the spirit of the
original of course you would have
returning characters Fred Savage
everybody coming back but at the same
time it would tap into what is popular
today because that kind of event while
you know a big set piece in the original
is now what's happening in gaming and I
think it makes perfect sense to go back
to this world and to do a follow up all
right we're getting totally 80s find it
out
well dad I think that's you made a
really good choice but I feel like you
got it backwards given the way gaming
culture is there's like no reverence for
the past know what no one who plays
overwatch looks up to the best Donkey
Kong jr. player like they hate their
parents they hate old games if it were
the other way where it was Fred Savage
like I gotta have one last ride and go
compete in this overwatch tournament to
impress my like dick son who's lost on
like Xbox Live Yellin slurs at people
like that's that's insane oh that's the
great thing about it though is this kid
is a little snot-nosed Punk and he has
no reverence for the past and that's
what his dad has to teach him because
it's not all about knowing the buttons
and everything it's it's 100% about
knowing the buttons how did he know
where that flute was that was impossible
to know some things are taught Spencer
some things are inside he felt the flute
and he has to teach his kid how to have
that same love it's not just about
playing the game it's about what's
inside your heart I question if there's
any wonder gaming anymore like the
wizard works because everyone's like oh
my god Super Mario Brothers 3 now gaming
cultured like kind of sucks well if they
could use a turn if they could use it to
premiere I don't know halo like people
would go crazy but the fart noise being
whatever halo we're on like I wanted to
just be called halo Portnoy's I think
you've all set up compelling reasons to
why this will be an interesting story
yes it's because things now you had an
interesting story in your fumblin you
know I'm undecided with the interesting
story is and I disagree fundamentally my
stories is interesting Jimmy wasn't
interested in video games he was
interested in going back to California
so he could put a photo of his dead
sister in that big dinosaur the crunch
that would hub of a wizard movie should
be maybe the kids grown up in those big
dinosaurs first of all you're both
pitching your ideas of what you think it
should be and I don't know what yours is
it has 17 different subtitles and you
literally just like so that's kid but
it's a boy that you want to do another
cool vampire movie set on the Santa Cruz
Boardwalk that's ridiculous in 80's and
a guy plays the sax and I want to reach
over Joe we're never going back better
version of yours those the whole point
was that you had this new crew of young
hot boys and you picked one girl you
need to have the next generation of
young actors in there and he pitched a
movie about why her Satoshi she's the
kid sorry I was Pesa fiying that the
question was who has a kid they have the
kid but she has a whole new rat pack
sort of surrounding her I'm saying what
the I don't think that was in your
friend mr. wizard
wasn't that the kid loved video games
and was super into video games he just
happened to be good at him cuz cuz he
just he just was but he was the all-time
champion he was the decide product of
him trying to go to California
but that doesn't change what he did that
doesn't change who he was and what he
accomplished I got
a little more about these two movies
yeah where's well where's Lucas put pin
in Matt where's Lucas oh you'll find out
no you didn't put them in there I'm like
a junk dealer man I'm giving you a hint
of it you gotta come see Luke Skywalker
of this book though he's Luke Skywalker
the force awakens where's Lucas I think
everyone wants to see Jaden Smith stuck
in a barium mine for pennies a day
it's a classic fish out of water and
then okay second part of my film B story
is that the parents they don't want the
PR thing of like they lost their son so
they go on some patronizing like
pan-african music tour of like a Live
Aid with like Madonna and Brad Pitt go
but they're secretly looking for their
kid this is comedy gold
this this sounds really weird and
depressing it's gonna lie it's way too
far away to from coming to America like
this is like a guy from from from wealth
from who's protected coming from a
unfamiliar place looking to be find
royalty but it's in a different link
gods must be crazy
yeah you're doing the same thing that
every 80s and 90s movie did when they
had a sequel they were just like let's
do the first one but reverse it this
time
lots of Australia is coming to LA or
Elias coming down Cherie or whatever
Crocodile Dundee did I think I think
with a second Lost Boys movie there's a
lot of commentary and nostalgia like
there's been so many different weird
vampire genre since then you can sort of
poke at all of those I think you get a
weird cool Redemption story with Joel
Schumacher coming back to form and Robin
yeah he'll really bring it all the
nuance to this one and a quarry yeah
everything back from the first movie and
yes saying it's gonna be as good that
they've Creed did it Crete did it well
but that's what Crete did brought back
one person from the previous film a
proctologist trainers and Brandt brought
back all the elements of the original
film and did it well that in itself is
not a critique of whether or not
something like this could work I just
don't see how yours is a commentary
anything it just seems like a rehash of
The Lost Boys of and we're so
oversaturated with vampire stuff like
it's it's too soon to bring back
vampires well it's been a while it's
been it's been a couple years since we
Twilight it I think it's time to do some
vampires final I think you can totally
do some more fun weird vampire stuff
there's never there there's vampires
have been around and pop culture forever
for a reason you know and get sick of
them there's always a fun new weird take
on vampires I think nostalgia again is
is super back with the 80s except I
don't want to do is sort of like warm
fuzzy et the ambulance side of things
that stranger things did you want that
weird like sexy maybe everybody's in
this weird vampire cave doing each other
before they go to the oil guy play
saxophone next to the Bears all the
sparks again like that's that's that's
where I want to go back to that weird
80s Santa Cruz and just sort of see it
through fresh eyes and I might be the
only person wants to see this movie but
talk about the Lost Boys that length
vampire sex cave thank you Joe Spencer
or final thought I just think that
coming to America there's something
timeless about the story of like a fish
out of water
who's maybe a little sheltered but has a
good heart looking for love and the
misunderstandings and happenstance of
him and his best friend going on a
journey to an unfamiliar place along the
way I think that just yes it is just
flipping it but just flipping it
actually lends it to a whole new
situation to a whole new time time
period of modern day and to a whole new
location of like all over the world
whereas which is a new take on an old
classic that's what you want and Eddie
Murphy will show up at the end and it'll
be sweet and I'll shed a tear Thank You
Spencer
Dan Merle my pitch is not just about
reliving the 80s and the Lost Boys and
it's not just taking the
fish-out-of-water concept my pitch is
about taking the concept of the first
movie the characters from the first
movie and updating it for a new
generation this is a story about a son
struggling to get out of the shadow of
his father it's a story about
generations struggling to connect to
each other it's tied into video games
video games are still relevant the
relevant in a much different way than
they were when the original was made I
don't think this is just going to be a
retread
another comedy trope this is gonna be I
think really an actually interesting
update on the original film it's gonna
hit the current thing for kids alike
video games now it's gonna hit the
nostalgia for people that liked this
movie and like the old NES games and I
think it'd be a really fun and
interesting movie - thank you Dad time
booyah Juan Harris what do we got in the
way of factual 'ti first of all in Super
Mario 3 it's called a warp whistle
everybody come on it makes a flute noise
kind of noise but it's called a warp
whistle in Crocodile Dundee - there were
questions we do return to Australia and
that was in New York in Berlin he goes
back to us you haven't said one to fight
against the Colombian drug cartel one
personal thing I was throwing we did
kind of have the long earring denim vest
80s guy in stranger things Billy
Hargrove in season 2 the bully
he's got the dangly year investing going
on so that that bet sort of effect
gotcha
oh go ahead and roll this into your
thoughts on this as much as I enjoyed
the creativity of Jones lost boys - :
lost boy :
it's a lost girl pants ultimately this
came down to for me I really I really
like Spencer's pitch although the line
that prints I came is now like Idi Amin
without the genocide nose caveat a
minute deposed King but I did like the
idea of travelling around the world with
you know like with his friends sort of
looking for her but ultimately I thought
Dan just did a really good job of taking
what worked about the wizard bringing it
into a modern context where it's still
super relevant I would like to hear what
the modern version of I love the power
glove it's so bad would be the art maybe
bomb dome Dan boom that's one for Dan
yeah I love the oiled-up
saxophone guy I'm so glad
yes I'm glad you brought him up but yeah
it also came down for Spencer and Dan
for me and I don't know I felt like they
they Joe and Spencer effectively like
started like hammering Dan's idea and it
wasn't quite fair because it was like a
real gang up like that sound like a man
I'm like two vampires under a boardwalk
but yeah just what was it what dis
questioning the angle questioning a lot
about it and I didn't hear a ton and for
me Spencer had the tightest a B
trajectory of his movie so I'm going
with coming from America even though I
wasn't sure about Jaden Smith in a
barium my James Smith type okay
why do you mean type yeah a lot of
compelling elements but just Spencer's
pitch seemed most airtight to me so
we're sending it to Danielle Radford so
here's the thing you can say Jaden Smith
type all you want it would be James
casting but he's getting cast in that
movie if he decides that he wants to be
cast in movies plus he'd get to rap I
mean yeah these were all very strong
arguments I do wish I would have heard
more of as much as I enjoyed hold on
look at my notes as much as I enjoyed
nostalgia is back but don't do the fuzzy
side maybe they're boning I know as much
as I enjoyed that I do wish I would have
gotten to hear more from Joe about his
pitch it's a PG show thirty parts though
the Blake's um
dance dance pitch was also very good I
that's another one where I feel like
there were arguments about Joe brought
up really good points about how that
wasn't at the center of the movie and
then Dan did have some really good
counter-argument to that why do you have
to say just as a solid pitch for a movie
and with some of the number-one video
games - a list of Dan's very good
impression Beetlejuice in the movie yeah
I know
by the way Spencer alternate title for
your movie the next King of Scotland
[Laughter]
okay
so it's one Oh Spencer our buddies Dan
and Joe looking to get on the board
question number two it's Thanksgiving
hope you're eating some pie and some
mashed potatoes and all that good stuff
we asked what movie characters house
would you most want to go to
Thanksgiving dinner for whoo what movie
characters house would you mutts most
want to go to to enjoy some Thanksgiving
dinner dinner floats - okay it's
question two we start with player -
Spencer all right I want to go to a
place that I didn't want to leave when I
saw it on film and that was at the end
of chef and that is the home of Jon
Favreau's character I believes names
Carl and
his son and his reunited wife Sofia
vegara as they are serving up a big meal
to the whole to friends and family
delicious food
her dad is like in a like a Latin jazz
band like they're playing it's
comfortable it's like indoor/outdoor in
Miami I mean you want food you want
friends you want family not just the
Olive Garden but at my Thanksgiving all
right Karl Jon Favreau's house from chef
Thank You Spencer
Dan Merle I like I'm a traditionalist I
like Thanksgiving food I like the I like
the family atmosphere I like fire you
only like three kinds of foods being a
little obtuse for the synthesis of humor
I like more than just I think things
literally okay so I'm going with Steve
Martin from playing trains and
automobiles
first of all just looking at what he
went through to get home for
Thanksgiving it is obvious that it is a
loving family it is a very nice house
we've seen that much they're talking
about the food they're talking about the
atmosphere they talk about the family
the entire movie is about that about
getting home plus it's a place that I
know I'm welcome that's the wonderful
that's the best moment in that movie is
is when he brings John Candy into his
home and welcomes him to his table
that's the kind of atmosphere I won't
for Thanksgiving house that's what
Thanksgiving is all about and that's
where I would want to go that's nice
Steve Martin's house from planes trains
and automobiles one of the great
Thanksgiving movies of all time
Joe star how I went with an answer so
obvious I can't believe I'm the only one
that pitched it and that is the
Merriman's tree house fortress from
Robin Hood Princess
oh yeah a little on the nose Joe don't
you think not only is the meal gonna be
good cuz it's gonna be fresh meat that
just got shot and it's being cooked over
a fire right in front of you
it could be boar it could be wild turkey
it could be all sorts of like you know
people ate before Thanksgiving happened
they ate all sorts of foods so your
food's gonna be awesome
you're gonna instead of someone buying a
last-minute $5 bottle of wine from
7-eleven on the way to your house like
there's just gonna be like straight-up
Meade from Friar Tuck passed around and
a jar you get to hang out eat by
firepits it's super comfy it's super fun
and then afterwards there's all sorts
activities someone could teach you how
to shoot arrows you can zipline around
you can take some very nice hikes that
weird place where they have the quarter
staff bite that little River that's a
very pretty place to go have to walk
after a nice Thanksgiving meal I'm going
for the for the full package with a
whole bunch of merry men people happy
enough to identify specifically as Mary
Robin Hood's
very great and I would just like to
clarify this is Kevin Costner's Robin
Hood not Taran edgerton's or Russell
Crowe Robin oh yeah I'm talking about
the only Robin Hood that's not also an
animated Fox that matters okay there we
go Kevin Costner's Robin a bunch of
these treehouse fortress fight it out
y'all my problem with Joe's pick is not
only will they not be serving at
Thanksgiving food there because it
predates Thanksgiving I've done turkey
plenty of times the last thing last
thing that I want to do on my
Thanksgiving Day is playing history
spoiler alert with a bunch of homeless
Englishmen I don't want to explain what
this what is this crazy concept that you
have well there's this holiday cheer
it's like well listen some shits gonna
go down I'll even grant you that
Thanksgiving exists in this land at the
time
say they you taught them all
Thanksgiving ahead time I don't want to
be having Thanksgiving looking over my
shoulder that the fuzz is gonna bust any
second okay
grab our pelts and run into the forest
these aren't dinner one time your
can happen at anybody's house it can
happen at his house it can happen at
Steve Martin's house look at all the
weird bad luck that follow you're not
manga bugs the huddling from the law
like in in are throwing their very
comfortably limping in a very very cool
treehouse region I'm not worried about
the fuzz dating Sharon for us I'm
worried about the fuzz that's still
gonna be on the dinner I don't what
stood rabbits that was like whoa did
will scarlet catch anything today
today's menu criticism from a guy that
eats three foods at Thanksgiving explain
an exaggeration for the sake of humor to
you I do think that food should be the
first consideration because family you
know it's all give or take it why not go
with the professional chef who can dress
things up and can dress things down his
whole family cooks they all have a great
appreciation for it they just got back
from that awesome road trip probably
picked up some cool recipes you have
some great sides some great firsts you
know these are chefs they're
professional entertainers for Alex how
you I'll tell you why specifically for
Thanksgiving I'm not gonna go through
your choice it is because I think that I
as I said I'm a traditionalist and I
feel like this is where our two are two
geographical upbringings because I found
that in California and people from
California Thanksgiving is kind of more
based around any kind of food it's it's
a little more very probably based my
Thanksgiving is as plain as the days
because the one thing there's gonna be
all these chefs sort of like trying to
outdo each other who would want chefs
try to outdo each other for things I
basic I want my good Thanksgiving like
just well-cooked meat basics I don't
want a bunch of guys ruining things in
particular is the whole movie the reason
that he goes on this trip is predicated
on the fact that he can't do the
classics he wants to go do other stuff
and every time he tries to do the
classics so that why he goes
to rediscover his passion for food and
find people like cooking from their
hearts and that their roots and that's
what he comes back with it doesn't want
to do the normal thing he wants to go do
the weird crazy things campanos ham and
cheese sandwiches he's not doing
craziness but he doesn't want to go by
the formula he wants to like experiment
and like I appreciate that in a chef but
that's not what I want for Thanksgiving
like I want that I want the the
tradition that Thanksgiving tradition
and that's what you're gonna get with my
choice you're gonna get a great meal
you're gonna get good family and a
welcoming atmosphere
I don't know about that family I hate to
bring this up but when they come home at
the end that family is old and weird
looking and they're little boys and who
is in culottes and a bow tied what kind
of like stilted conversation gonna have
when the little boy is wearing culottes
and he looks like Oliver Twist and then
everyone in there everyone else aside
from his wife is over 70 you're not
gonna just be like mental bastard
Spencer this is a family that brought in
a man bigoted bring him in he brought
him in after he wore him down
psychologically to their table is that
not what Thanksgiving is about is about
finding people and welcoming to them to
your table that's what the entire
holidays predicated they welcomed with
open arms are were they afraid of an
angry patriarch who's been shown to have
a short temper and to not welcome in
guess at first sight he had to have a
whole hero's journey to find out that
people that strangers were worth
trusting and were worth bringing and
this was clearly the first time he's
ever done there's a most cynical man in
the world
I get the love I watched the beginning
of the movie and the end the love is
there at the end
there at the beginning Steve Martin
learns to love the old families they're
like ugh dad does it come about love and
acceptance that's the whole night he has
to learn loved and accepted and he's
welcoming into his house you're taking
you're taking the steamer at the
beginning of the movie and saying he's
destined at the end and he's not the
project's about him learning to appease
the product of his family environment
home so bad cuz he's just stressed out
about the whole thing because he knows
he's gonna go home is weird cool out
kid's gonna be a brad cuz they hate late
this is a guy who works hard who wants
nothing more than to go home to his
family to the place where he is loved to
a house of love and warmth and you're
both bringing the most cynical thing
possible this is about warmth and
understanding it's not about hanging out
hobos in the forest and it's not about a
chef sailing I just thought I put
avocado on the turkey and I smear
tonight Kaiser wrap you wanted yam sorry
I don't do that they're boring I'm with
you on that he's gonna it's gonna be
awesome I want a family
seasoned unflavored like they're
probably gonna do it out of a package
and it's gonna be very very plain
I'm gonna ask you to give us your final
thoughts and and paint us a look I'm
gonna ask each of you in your final
thoughts to paint us a lovely
Thanksgiving picture look I want to have
fun I want friends I want music I want a
little bit of liveliness and in my
Thanksgiving it's a celebration it's a
celebration of family it's a celebration
of food most of all and these are all
people who love each other and they love
food I just don't send it's in a nice
Miami climate like who doesn't want to
be you know in a t-shirt and shorts for
Thanksgiving yeah you're all you all
move to California I just think it's got
everything you want and yes I like my
Thanksgiving with a little bit of spice
I'm not gonna apologize for it typical
California leaders I'm thinking we all
moved here for the climate knows
spencer we didn't some of us had other
motives Thanksgiving in Arkansas I've
talked to you guys you want to buy the
plane ticket Spencer and I'll take the
money yes please thank you and the
reason that I would like to go home for
that is because that's what I love about
Thanksgiving I love the welcoming
atmosphere I love the love about it I
love the fact the spirit of the holiday
and that's one of the great things that
actually happens in LA is so many people
get together and welcome people that
don't have anywhere else to go that come
into their home for the holiday that's
the kind of place that I want to spend
Thanksgiving in particular not into
place that just has nice food not a tree
for sure but a place that knows what the
what the holiday is about a place
that is going to welcome you with open
arms and that's why this is where you
want to go this place represents the
spirit of the holiday thank you Dan
Joestar so finally I don't want to go
somewhere that's just you say it's just
gonna be about the food and you want a
little bit of spice but I feel like in
this competitive chef situation it's
gonna be like when you go to a wedding
reception and they're like we got the
finest vegan chef in Berkeley to cook
all the food and everyone's kind of just
like picking through their plate and
trying to find and then you go get a
slice of pizza when no one's looking and
I just don't think that's gonna be a
very fun Thanksgiving I'll grant you
you're gonna have a very nice
Thanksgiving but I want I want that
little bit of extra cuz I can go have
that nice Thanksgiving just like at my
parents house but when we're given the
option of you can go have this
Thanksgiving Day with any movie
character I want to do something I'm
gonna remember I want something that's a
little crazy a little crazier a little
more memorable you guys talked about
having friends music love and food and
those are all things that happen
pleasure in a cool forest in a cool tree
house eaten venison over the fire like
friend roasted vegetables
this is good sorry
cooking fresh rabbit not a bunch of
store-bought stuff this is this is legit
fresh organic food like that's gonna be
really really awesome food that you know
the Favreau's and stuff with all of
their skill and talent aren't gonna be
able to prepare plus there's just going
to be fun stuff to do there's cool
people there and it's a whole community
of people coming together for one really
big fun Thanksgiving festival and just
to answer that final knock of maybe the
sheriff of Nottingham's people show up
and maybe they start trying to raise the
village maybe allegedly I'll see this
house I'm getting old and all these
holidays are starting to bleed together
and that's depressing to me and
Thanksgiving that I will not forget is
the one when Morgan Freeman throws me a
seminar that's gonna be an awesome one
that I'm not gonna forget when Morgan
Freeman's just like Christian come on
and then I follow him into battle
right before we have a lovely dessert
Joe start pitching an unforgettable
Thanksgiving nickname
alright time Wow
all sorts of three very different
Thanksgivings lawn Harris where we at
with the facts John Piper plays a
character named Carl Casper and chef so
you're correct his name is Carl Steve
Martin by the way for the record Neal
page this is character played series
normal bits it's the only real fact I
had to check the fauna common to
Sherwood Forest you've got rabbit you've
got vole with your small rodents chugs
scopes weasels foxes badgers bats and
fallow deer what's your small deer it's
like edible so you could make it all
taste on rabbits do and your venison to
theoretically work yeah
Hasenpfeffer is a rabbit dish that I
learned about by watching Bugs Bunny
Hasenpfeffer and pepper make up a
Hasenpfeffer a fricassee enjoy your vote
in this movie there are big deer in that
forest that's why I kid gets arrested
because he's shooting a big killing the
Kings deer crab denoted Daniel Radford
okay I have so many notes and none of
them make sense all of these words
obviously good arguments I you know at
first I was kind of downplaying Joe's
but Joe had that really great moment
where he said like if I want something
traditional when I can go home if I want
something memorable then that's why I'm
going to this and I thought that that
was a really really compelling argument
Spencer I'm sorry but they're right
chefs food is gonna make me angry I just
won Koreans my dude and I appreciate
that chef is probably gonna do something
very interesting with pears but I don't
need to eat it so this was really
between Joe
which means Joe and Dan for me and yeah
I gotta say I loved all of the things
about tradition it being so warm and
welcoming at home but Joe's right if I
went home I'm going back to Seattle so I
have to go okay Oh for the Merry Men
yeah I agree and disagree somewhat with
a lot of your points Danielle I was I
was I pushed my chips into the middle of
the table for Spencer real quick but
then I started be like dealer
hold that thought it's like man they
kept dinging you and that like just man
I just started thinking about just weird
concoctions that made Thanksgiving
unfortunate you saw the movie right
didn't you want to eat everything now
and then Dan had a good point
he got railroaded by the food critic he
got a bad review because he did not want
to cook traditional so yeah it was a
combination of those things that they
really knocked out of contention for me
Joe you came up
hard at the end with that memorable
Thanksgiving stuff because how many do
you have
but at the end of the day Dan just
painted this bucolic picture of home and
the question is what movie characters
house would you most want to go to for
Thanksgiving dinner
and that atmosphere of love and
acceptance they accepted an unkempt lout
who in the airport when Steve Martin met
him he was reading a pornography The
Canadian Mounted I go with Dan Moreau on
this one so we're sending it to lawn
Harris oh wow tough tough call I was
also between Joe and dad because I kind
of agree like pretentious to me like
hanging out with chefs on Thanksgiving
I'm not I'm not sure they're good so I
was between Joe dead about to say it was
leaning towards Dan the whole time but I
thought Joe had a very effective final
rebuttal I agree that the the appeal of
meal pages has to be end of plain
straights isn't that it's the greatest
Thanksgiving ever it's it's somewhere to
go he was gonna be alone now he has a
chance to be with someone but if I had
my choice of where to go I think Jill
made a very strong case for why Sheriff
are scary
heartless heartless I you know what you
made it you pierce this dark heart my
leg with a pen lost voice to marry men
keepin the bone I was waiting for
someone to say how bitter cold it was
gonna be so Joe takes it with
Thanksgiving in the woods one for Joe
one for Spencer Dan looking to get on
the board and whoa hey by the door it's
a blind fight Perceval what do you think
about the blind fight I'm excited
all right so we recently cleaned out the
screen junkies toy closet and we came
upon a Billy bootleg Universal hero
action figure Sam oh no ok ok maybe show
the people at home what kids don't want
to play Universe Avengers knockoff yeah
Jordan air huh ok who are the Avengers
how these are the universe arrow it's
the universal heroes oh my god I want it
so bad oh so much yeah oh look at his
eyes his eyes light up when he was maple
can you show the people I - I don't know
if they could see this but oh here let
me uh yeah there you go
alright so ok no power blind by his
asking you three great minds to create
and pitch the universal hero movie
hich the universal hero movie and Daniel
Radford lawn Harris and myself are the
studio execs and the people out there
let us know in the comments they don't
have a name like alright okay they they
don't have names you supply the man okay
so the audience will just know who we're
talking about alright and Dan and
everybody as you're pitching you want to
have that and maybe in front of you yeah
yeah oh great alright Dan your player
number three this is question number
three you are first up mom I am okay so
this is the universal hero movie this is
called team of might is the name of my
film starring these Universal hero
figures team of might this one is a
flash man flash man but he's not fast
that's the twist that's what keeps him
from being completely a derivative as
name is flash man and he's axe it's just
a quick thinker I think no problem any
problem they all go to the same tailor
that's why all the costumes look the
same this is captain might captain might
he's actually from the UK these are not
the American Stars and Stripes this is
the British these are the British
colonies yeah Union Jack short this is a
this is a scorpion wing right here
that's scorpion wing he can fly he's
also a demon which is what explains the
light up eyes scorpion wing there this
guy is really cool he lives up he it
looks like he would not live underwater
but he does this is the seahorse he can
zip through water faster than you can
ever imagine and he made some life no
they're very they're very
[Laughter]
when is this guy and this guy this guy
is sense of justice he's the moral
center of the group and really they're
they're a ragtag bunch of people and
they're clones
yeah whoa yeah look that's very similar
alert that's in the twist and they're
clones and they fight crime in Japan
okay maybe the brodster right back
around to joe oh okay got a tag bunch of
clones that fight crime in japan okay so
the first couple things that sort of
stand out to me here is everyone looks
you know the same obviously these are
different repaints on different
characters there's some weird tech stuff
there's some bad stuff so here we go
Universal heroes decades ago the world's
greatest hero was basically a tech guy
tech hero that's like an amalgam of
Batman and Iron Man and he loses evil
wins evil controls the world it's very
very very dark grim future until a group
of cool teens with attitude five his
cave the the Batman Iron Man guys cave
and find all of his crap and instead of
one guy is using very specific armor for
very specific situations like oh I have
to go to a winter place time to put on
Arctic attack Batman clothes they just
use all of his stuff and sort of throw
it all together as big of Malcolm's
one's got bat wings one of them's got a
cicada head throws at people this guy's
blue and this guy has a big sword and
that looks like it turns into a demon
dog so he was very occult guy apparently
too but then that's that is that these
kids find all this stuff and they fight
evil with it
mmm Spencer okay gosh okay so the
universal Heroes this takes place look
if Deadpool can say
DCE you can they say Avengers can we say
that they this is a non-canonical MCU
movie we won't refer to them by name
we'll just say like those heroes or the
revenge errs if you need to come up with
like a facsimile of them
these are the castoffs these are the
heroes that you that are basically like
the heroes of Reseda
like they're the vendors take care of
like South Korea and when sail is under
attack or the entire universe or sokovia
the universal heroes are just kind of
the kroger brand there are little little
Genki in their equipment they all have
to clearly share the same suit just kind
of die different colors there they're
the naired do wells and they're
overlooked and they get bullied by other
superhero it's like the The Avengers or
similar or like you will take care of
this one Universal heroes like this
isn't a this isn't a speeding ticket
we're trying to save the world but in
their hubris perhaps because of a snap
perhaps because of a you know an
invention of their own creation all the
biggest heroes die and the government's
like who do we got and it's like the Bad
News Bears of superheroes the universal
knockoff falling apart heroes but they
got a lot of heart and they got a lot of
junk the pickins trap together to form
larger junk and they are forced to step
it up because they have the real
humility and the real strength of
resolve that that the big-time hero is
lost by being so popular in our comics
obsessed days gotcha and - question for
Spencer are you saying that this is part
your are you positing that these guys in
your movie are part of the MC if we can
get the rights great probably not so
that's just winkin yeah otherwise we're
just saying like by the you know Effie
man and like you know cat boy okay fight
it out everybody we've tried in this
ground before year we've made this
series already it was called interns
afield and it was not particularly well
received so I wonder
as easily several key differences one
money to not behind a paywall
three this is yeah this is a film this
is this doesn't have the pitfalls of a
pilot and a series that you have to get
people on board right away this has time
to develop and time to create a world
that people want to be well the app that
this is available on work no I mean it
sounds kind of like Mystery Men I feel
like with Mystery Men like the heroes
are out of commission and you got the BT
man and yours is basically Power Rangers
heck yeah man it's what I love about
team a might it may seem derivative but
the scene went sense of justice is being
when his sense of justice is being
tested by my supervillain and he's the
moral center of this team you're really
gonna care about these guys they
overcome their obstacles they have so
many things going against them seahorse
as I mentioned who makes for life falls
in love with the wrong with the
supervillain and you can imagine how
distressing that would be his
inclination is to mate for life
there are many different ways that you
can go with my super team they all fit
together they don't fit together you did
fantastic beasts doing it where like
there's five different stories going on
at the same time I'm missing like the
overarching thing you got one like
non-consensual seahorse relationship you
got one did not say that
well it's calling hey it's not
non-competitive element doesn't want to
be with the seahorse and he's going
after no it's the opposite the seahorse
you're not listening my villain yeah
yeah is Captain wrong and the captain's
horse captain rogues wrong that doesn't
take a sense of justice integrity of
you don't notice these things until
they're too late that dr. evil got a
degree but people didn't seem to catch
on so later for him either that's fair
sometimes you're just born with a proper
surname it happens but I I'm really
aiming to create something original here
I don't want to be derivative of
anything else I realized that perhaps
you look if you look at this package and
you look at these faces you're like oh I
know where this is going you don't know
where this is going
captain might I think particularly I've
got a great arc for him in the first
film that could set up his own solo
movie I don't think it's gonna be too
much going on because I'm very
self-assured and what these characters
are who their identities are and and and
that's the thing it's not having too
many stories going on at once it's not
having confidence in those stories I'm
very confident that these five
characters are strong enough to please
for one second I'm gonna throw something
at you guys I'm gonna ask that you guys
give me the title of your film and then
the tagline like this summer you won't
know what hit you or in space no one can
hear you scream
or whatever you guys know what I'm
talking about so I want you to give us
the title of your film and the tagline
and yeah give it to us with a little bit
of a little bit of hot sauce on it
give us some pizzazz all right Dan okay
first again it's just the futures
Universal Universal Heroes and then you
see the silhouette of a giant robot
forming and it punches a castle oh so
it's like Power Rangers and Voltron yeah
I'm doing so many derivative things and
I'm really really excited about it
nicely okay I think it's gonna be really
really good yeah mine's Universal Heroes
was it it's like Universal heroes 90%
effective a hundred percent authentic
okay great thanks Spence dan I think
that you can do a lot of different
marketing strategies I think the moon I
think the more traditional way would be
you know a team of might heroes
Universal heroes heroes for the universe
I
it's one thing that's the more thing but
I think you could go into the more to
the the more modern market go for the
viral market and it'd be like are they
heroes are the dance I've seen you can
go to the you can go any number of ways
and this is what I also love is is
you're gonna hit a lot of different
camps with this movie this is a four
quadrant picture that you can market to
a lot of different audiences sure great
great anything else to add you guys yeah
I'll say let's have a final thought yeah
to the critique that a group of ragtag
superheroes taking over for for a cocky
original guard it's something that's
been done not just in Mystery Men but in
Watchmen and it's been done effectively
and both of those movies were movies
that came out before their time I feel
like now people understand so much about
the superhero tropes and have seen the
superheroes literally get big heads and
become too big for maybe what the movies
uh started out as that it's time for the
for a bad news bears but with
superheroes Thank You Spencer
dan I would I would argue that Watchmen
probably didn't come out before any tie
I visited Watchmen and it's I'm about
the same on it but even the idea of a
bad news bears but for superheroes they
had that movie the losers which was sort
of the like it was based on a comic book
it's the same thing it's it's I get it
that you know perhaps the stones were
underappreciated but I don't think they
change the fundamental thing it's like
this concept has been done before
whereas what I am pitching is a
completely new team of original
superheroes I promise you've never seen
anyone like seahorse and a superhero
film before and looking for innovation a
unique look in a unique take and I feel
like we've seen Spencer's take before
and Joe's just kind of seems to be we
just got a Power Rangers movie you even
use teenagers with attitude and go into
a cave and discover a thing we just we
just saw that so I feel like my take is
really in may it may be unconventional
but its original and I think that's what
people are looking for thank you Dan Joe
start he'll I'll add great Lake Avengers
to the pile of things that Spencer's
sounds like there's just sitting you
know there's a lot of a lot of CIC has
story all bunch
with that question I questioned Dan's
decision to really work on focusing on
character and arcs for this giant a big
ridiculous Universal hero movie people
people go in to see popcorn movies they
don't they don't want characters they
don't nuance what I want to do is I want
to take the best of a bunch of existing
IPs
smash them all together and pretend them
original and present them in a whole new
different dark harder way I'm going to
take all the buzzwords that everyone who
complains about comic movies say like it
would have been better if it was our or
I like Zack Snyder or whatever it is
that they say on the internet and I'm
going to cater to all of them
so you're Starship Troopers in it like
it's a satire of the source material the
universal heroes Canon satire is what
gives you peace with enjoying it then
yes absolutely
but nope value I'm just mixing up Batman
and Iron Man Power Rangers and and the
flash-forward scenes from Justice League
and I'm making it look like that time
wow wow wow all right there it is
Universal heroes it's long not a lot of
facts to check you know dr. evil went to
evil medical school so it wasn't a
surprise a legacy for life oh good good
but I will take a look I mean I know
penguins do mm-hm they do sea horses
mate for life complete it yeah seahorse
m18 it was like
trust me they do hey Google really
wanted us to know um yeah so Dan Joe
said you spelling out what everyone is
did not work for you but I thought it
did my point goes for Dan alright there
you go about seaboards yeah I thought
you know at first I thought that that
would hold Dan back because he wasn't
getting into the pitch but everybody
else was so general Joe you started to
win me over at the end I almost went Joe
I almost went Joestar sometimes they do
yeah and but they and they really dinged
you with they they were like bam bam bam
they were like making it rain we're just
trying to make a real movie here now I'm
trying to reinvent the wheel with and I
also was on the yeah Mystery Men and
several others but yeah Dan's attention
to detail took it for me the ragtag crew
him clones in Japan lon Harris I feel
like if Spencer had stuck with his
original Reseda Avengers concept that
was a really strong sort of title and
concept but I felt like yeah we got too
far away which is kind of like they'll
help the Arby's there yeah they're like
they're offshoots they're the ragtag I
thought the other fighters did a really
good job of sort of yeah we've kind of
seen in terms of field Mystery Men we've
seen that story sort of Dan vs. Joe and
ultimately I agree I think that Dan's
level of specificity I knew who all
those characters are I get a sense for
the team dynamics you know what like
sense of justice is gonna take over
versus when it's sort of Captain might
so I'm going with Dan as well yeah oh
and watch out for the demons clapping
Ling we had another catchphrase for
Dan's yeah let me see if I can find it
oh are they heroes which they might be
my and my tis kind of bolded because
captain my captain is Daniele anyone on
Twitter make a meme of Universal Heroes
Jessica there's a lot of good movie
posters to come out of today's I think I
mean oh hell yeah oh guess what it's a
great moment in sports because we are
all tied up 1 1 1 gentlemen you've
pushed it to the limit and here is our
tiebreaker okay and again you guys know
this but for everyone tiebreak works
more or less the same as the speed round
they answer they call out their answers
and then we have them elaborate in the
order that they called out their answers
they first get 20 seconds each and then
10-second rebuttals and then we choose
Danielle lon and myself who sadly will
not move on to the speed round all right
here is our tiebreaking question call it
the answer when you know what you want
to say what's the best action movie of
2018 I always get the title wrong but
you'll know what I'm talking about it's
the one with the raid guys and I think
it's called the knight comes for us okay
there you go
[Laughter]
hmm Oh the spy who dumped me mm-hmm I'll
go I'll go mission impossible fall out I
fall out all right three very different
very good answers so we're so we're
going to hear from Spencer damn Joe and
then rebuttals in the same order
Spencer 20 seconds again when you speak
it's missing the director from the raid
but and to but it has everybody else it
has the martial artist it's set in
modern-day Indonesia where everyone owns
a machete everyone's going crazy on each
other all the time the stunt work is
impeccable
I wonder how these people survived the
shooting of the movie a guy beats maybe
17 people to death with the pool table
all the various parts the balls the cue
the the netting and the spy who tell me
there's a movie that did not do out the
box-office and I think it was really
underrated critically it had a great
dynamic between Mila Kunis and kate
mckinnon had a great duo it was that
great set up of people that did the
unlikely action hero it really had a
great action sequences and it was kind
of a throwback to that 80's thing that
you don't see a whole lot anymore
I thought it was not only was it a great
action movie but I I think Tom Cruise
took the idea of the old 80s action star
and made it actually not cheesy and
awesome and big and shiny the way that
we like to remember 80s movies as the
the sequences in this movie are huge
that the the the chase on the motorcycle
the helicopter sequence the rooftop jump
the guy's doing his own stunts
everything is big and loud and really
well done just as tightly done as night
comes for us but on a much bigger scale
the neck of stress has quantity and
quality of action it has just enough
story of a bad guy who doesn't want to
be bad anymore getting revenge and all
the other bad guys and it's wall to wall
fighting on top of that it's it's really
I think that you get a lot of what these
other ones have in other movies you get
the big set pieces nor the Mission
Impossible movie Zico who always way was
in mile 22 which also came out the shoe
that had the same style of fighting I
think he had a great new duo which is
what makes the spy who dumped me great
I think night comes to our starts to
overwhelm you at times mission
impossible paces itself with peaks and
valleys a lot better and let you enjoy
each piece for what it is and just in
terms of just action movie in it out
does fine who dumped me
alright Wow
there we go Danielle Radford okay so
does not move for who does not move
forward yeah these were all great and
compelling arguments up I do have to say
that I was i've debt like definitely
more taken by Joe he had a great
argument about how Mission Possible
paces itself and how the action out does
by who dumps me but I did also
appreciate you know some of the
arguments about the pacing when it came
to the night comes for us so I'm gonna
go with as much as I love him Spencer or
not me anymore
gotcha okay so I I I thought Joe really
sold me and so it came down between us
Spencer and Dan I felt like Dan spent
part of his time proving that this was
an action movie worthy of these other
two whereas Spencer was just throwing
the action at me with his breakdown of
it so I was really compelled by these
two and Dan well fought but for me it's
Dan who does not move on lon
welcomes enemy yeah I agree that Joe is
on really safe ground he picked the
movie I probably would have picked him
in did a really good job sort of
defending it I like this point about you
know Tom Cruise kind of realizing the
80s archetype so they come down to Dan
versus Spencer ultimately I really like
Dan's argument about that it was more
than just the action it was a great sort
of overall movie that had great action
scenes in it whereas I thought Spencer
focused on here's how great the action
is without sort of talking about
anything else having to do with the
movie so I'm going to say that Spencer
drops out
spend some well-fought thank you for
playing but you sir will be spectating
in this speed round alright Dan and
yours right and people should see that
movie if you haven't right recommend all
three of these movies they're all right
moves I don't remember the mission of
possible came out this year
right on all right great movie miss
spike don't may I recommend it no good
stuff good stuff yes
three solid movies that everyone should
watch if they haven't seen them all
right so that tiebreak did not count for
a point we are tied at 1-1 going into
this speed round and it works the same
way the last question just did alright
here we go question one of the speed
round best movie set on or around a
major holiday night hard die hard it's a
wonderful life it's a wonderful life all
right Joe 20 seconds begin when you
speak I think die hard gives you the
same values as if it's a wonderful life
one man has worth but it gives you
badass action and the fight scenes and
explosions and shooting and squibs and
now I have a machine gun hohoho and one
of the greatest villains of all time
it's a great it hits all it really hits
all the Christmas traditions and
messages and morals that you want it to
hit while Bruce Willis beats the crap
out of vaguely European terrorists I
would disagree that hits the Christmas
message the more as a matter fact people
can't even agree that it is a Christmas
movie It's a Wonderful Life is a classic
and it transcends the holiday is a
wonderful Christmas movie but it is also
about you as you said one man's worth
but not just one man's worth to one
night one man's worth to all of the
lives that intersected his it shows you
how much you can touch the lives of
other and how much you count as a person
I mean I think if saving all those
people from that building and those
terrorists don't teach you that the
you're worth something as a person I
don't know it does this movie it's not a
great Christmas movie but it's the
better movie set around the holiday
I disagree it's a Wonderful Life is
universal you can't show die hard to
just anybody you can't show it to kids
you can't show it to older people they
might not like it everyone can enjoy
It's a Wonderful Life and its message
transcends to all ages across all genres
okay Dan took that one from me his
opening round just pierced my again my
dark cold heart yeah but that really
resonated Danielle yeah I have to agree
both of them came out the gate with
really strong arguments but that last
thing about it you know die hard is
great but you can't show it to everyone
you might not want to show it to kids
and for a Christmas movie it does need
to be something that appeals to as many
people as possible so I gotta go damn
alright Dan you move ahead two two one
all right I thought die hard I was like
that was a great answer and then Dan
Mosley It's a Wonderful Life Dan yeah
okay we were talking about this great
Thanksgiving movie earlier an honor of
train planes trains and automobiles John
Candy or Steve Martin John Candy these
choice they don't have to pick joke okay
so this is this is just in in general in
general just in general okay so we heard
John Candy first from Dan Joe will be on
on the way back with the Steve Martin I
love both of them but inside of the back
of my head when I'm watching a Steve
Martin performance I'm always very aware
that it is a Steve Martin performance
whereas John Candy is the everyman he
feels like he could be your next-door
neighbor he feels like he could be your
uncle he feels like he can be that guy
in the airport who offers you a ride
home so you can be with your kid at
Christmas there's a certain endearing
quality to him that I think a lot of pee
took the heart and I think that's a
wonderful quality about candy but when
you're talking about sort of a pound or
pound full resume that's the one well
that he always went back to where as
Steve Martin had so much rain he had the
absurdity of the jerk he could do
romantic comedy with father the bride he
could do more broad silly slapstick with
three amigos I think the guy just has
more in his arsenal than John Candy did
so I think he played more different
kinds of roles but I think that John
Candy actually showed a lot of range he
was also in things like the Blues
Brothers that weren't necessarily in the
same thing I just think as a personality
I personally take him to be more
endearing more personal
I think when your job is a comedic actor
and Dearing is great yes but funny is
first funny is the rule and I think
Steve Martin just pound for pound has
funnier rolls funnier movies of funnier
complete IMDB all right all of that
gross with an unbeatable task I thought
you both did well on what do you think
yeah
tough question I thought both fighters
did great ultimately I think I was more
swayed by Joe and his argument for Steve
Martin taking on such a wide variety of
roles whereas John Cady did kind of
stick to that sort of heartwarming
endearing charming kind of mode so I'm
going with Joe for the same reasons I'm
also going with Joe we are locked up at
two - here we go question number three
of the speed round which superhero
should we be more excited for which
superhero movie shall we be more excited
for Aquaman or into the spider version
on spider-verse
okay I heard Aquaman first from Joe and
Dan got his first pick because he said
into the spider verse just moments after
Joe began to say Aquaman we play the
heck
okay so Joe 20 seconds begin when you
speak Dan coming around the bend with
into the spider verse I think our
favorite comic book movies are the ones
that have tapped into other genres and
played with them guardians was a space
opera Winter Soldier was a political
thriller
Aquaman looks to fulfill the promise of
just crazy 80s high fantasy which is
crazy trippy colors and and huge epic
scope battles and insane visuals with
underwater sharks and people are riding
on them I described a lot of what we've
seen in the trailers for Aquaman but we
know this character already he's been in
two previous films we know the outlines
we kind of the sandbox this character is
playing in into the spider-verse is
great because you have number one the
format bending
the animation can do and number two you
have so many different versions of the
character interacting that you're not
going to be constrained to just this
particular interpretation of Aquaman
into the spider Chris has a really good
chance of falling into a convoluted mess
of I'm a different spider-man and I'm a
different spider-man instead of focusing
on a really cool core story
Aquaman we want to see this character
step up from the the previous Snyder
stuff if you want to talk about the
dangers of something falling into a
convoluted mess I would not pick a movie
from the DCE you my friend whereas we
have lured Anil we're providing the
script for this they are proven to have
a proven track record as strong writers
and I can't wait to see what they do oh
man both good answers but yeah damn
painted the got me more a little bit
more excited about his and then he had
some great retorts so I go damn he won
them Danielle yeah Jeremy won that one
really had me with the convoluted messed
thing and then where I come from we call
this game point
okay so Joe you need to need your scene
actually anywhere you'd be from this
would be game point so Joe you need it
to tie the game Dan you take this you
take the day better Pixar sequel finding
dory or Incredibles - Incredibles -
finding dory
okay so we have Incredibles - from Joe
down I'll be coming around the bend with
dory Joe 20 seconds begin whenever you
speak
I think both of these movies suffer from
repeating the beats of the first one but
Incredibles 2 looks visually stunning
it's beautiful the the action sequences
are huge I would I would recommend the
movie just for the train chase alone
with the with the cool stuff with the
Alaska bike
whereas Dori relies solely on the charm
of Ellen and that performance
Incredibles offers you all do visuals
and really cool superpower fights I
don't think it credible Stu offers as
much new as a lot of people say that it
does it's essentially the first movie
but you just swap the roles of mr.
incredible and mrs. incredible whereas I
think that finding dory takes a
completely new look at the character in
a completely new space you go into the
zoo you have a lot of new people for
them to interact with it's returning to
the world but telling the story the
different character is Incredibles to is
sort of just a rehash of the original
because people liked it I feel like both
of these are rehashing it's it's a
question of which one do you want to
watch again and I think Incredibles 2 it
has that rewatched power it's just a
more fun movie it's loud and exciting
it's colorful and I think the same can
be said of the first movie if you're
talking about the one that I want to
watch right now it's one that's the most
different from the other one Incredibles
2 is very similar to the first
incredible responding boys a completely
separate story from the front from
Finding Nemo and that's what I want to
see all right long I think I have to go
down on this one I feel like he did a
better job of explaining how finding
dory sort of changes the formula and
mixes things up whereas incredible is
just kind of like takes what people like
from the first one and Andrey does it so
yeah so I think Dan Danielle yeah I mean
they both there's essentially the same
argument both about the rehashing about
one being more I do like how much Joe
talked about the action bits but as far
as just saying which one since that was
the core argument of both of that it was
a rehash Dan was the one who brought the
more compelling argument to kind of take
that down so I got to go down happy
Thanksgiving Dan you just won
[Music]
[Laughter]
nicely done my man Dan give us some give
us something what are you thankful for
I'm thankful for so many things I'm
always thankful for my family I'm
thankful for my girlfriend I'm thankful
for my friends who I also get too lucky
to count as my co-workers and then my
friends outside of work I'm thankful for
a lot of things that particularly just
even of these last few weeks there are
so many things that the fact that we're
still here is something to be thankful
for
so yeah IIIi will be giving many thanks
as this is airing I'm very thankful for
a lot of things thanks brother
nicely done well played Oh devastating
speed around to Joe star you play damn
good today and you're also just funny
and adorable Bobby what do you thankful
for my friend oh man yeah I'm thankful
for this this bunch of idiots that come
in coming in to work here as always you
got to remind yourself that uh it's
definitely sort of a dream job that we
sort of made up and shouldn't exist but
I'm really thankful that I get to come
in and do this stuff with you guys every
day I'm grateful that we get to cosplay
as the writers room that people want
honest trailers to be whenever someone's
like I wish you would just film the room
every day cuz usually were just kind of
quiet so I'm glad we get to come out and
yell at each other and riff a little bit
and I'm thankful that uh I'll be
spending Thanksgiving with this guy and
he just gets to rub rub this win in all
day right on good times
Spencer hey Oh what am I saying all for
ya
you the viewer you at home you know
you're the silent majority who just
watches and enjoys you don't need to
comment you don't need to subscribe just
I hope you had a good time you know we
don't know we make no demands of you
just don't be mean yeah right on yeah
thanks Spencer and funny stuff today
well played lot Harris her Nick Sounion
to thank the silent majority turning
forty over this thankful for surviving
40 years on this planet and yeah getting
to do this everyday with these great
people and you know all the all the
screen junkies fans who interact with us
online and send us goofy stuff and watch
all these videos and comment I'm very
thankful to be part of something like
this and a project like this the way
I'll get to work on every day yeah
Danielle Radford yeah man I'm a super
grateful for every when I work with I'm
grateful for all of the very nice people
that continue to give me jobs I don't
deserve it but thanks I appreciate it I
am thankful for my friends and for my
family for my awesome partner I am
thankful that they did not have the
internet when I was young and stupid and
I'm very thankful that my mom's not on
Twitter
[Music]
I hear all that yeah I am uh I'm
thankful for my fiance for my blind in
one eye dog Millie and I'm thankful that
I get to echo someone what Dan was
saying like I get to show up here and
talk movies with the funniest most
knowledgeable movie people there are
it's like it's it's bonkers how much fun
is it to riff with these guys
that the London Calling over there and
it's the hole in this room oh my
goodness and uh I'm thankful for owls
and I'm thankful for the food I'm gonna
eat on Thanksgiving I'm thankful for you
guys everybody owl nation or shark
nation or whoever
[Laughter]
there's no chomping there's no yes but
mostly uh personable and Alla nation
thank you for watching movie freud's
everybody we'll see you next time and
I'm thankful for jte and Billy Biscoe
guys those guys holdin it down see you
next time bye bye
[Music]
you